[Música]
hace unos 500 años un chino llamado guau
tenía el sueño de alcanzar las estrellas
y una noche mientras miraba un
espectáculo de cohetes y fuegos
pirotécnicos se le curó la idea de
utilizar estos cohetes para poder llegar
al espacio
y diseñó un vehículo
una silla con 47 grandes cohetes en la
parte de abajo que según sus cálculos lo
harían lograr su objetivo
llegó el día y one who se sentó sobre su
vehículo 47 personas serían las
encargadas de encender cada uno de estos
cohetes al encenderlos una fuerte
explosión y una bola de humo inundaron
el lugar
cuando el humo se disipó
juanjo ya no estaba
y jamás se supo nada más de él
one hub es reconocido en la historia ya
que no solo sueño con llegar al espacio
sino que construyó un artefacto para
intentarlo aunque quizá no con la mejor
idea
pero como él y más personas en la
historia yo soy un apasionado de los
cohetes y de la exploración espacial
desde el momento en que mi asesor del
proyecto en la vocacional nos puso en la
película cielo de octubre el último día
de curso
y además de los cohetes y de la
exploración espacial nos ha dado grandes
beneficios en nuestra vida cotidiana la
comunicación celular localización global
medicina realidad aumentada robótica
prevención de desastres causados por
fenómenos naturales y desarrollo de
equipo médico especializado es más
podría decirles que todos en este lugar
usamos tecnología satelital y lo usamos
todos los días de alguna o de otra forma
el espacio me gustó mucho comencé a
investigar más e involucrarme en el tema
pero fue hasta el final de mi carrera
cuando un amigo me invitó a formar parte
de un equipo de desarrollo de tecnología
aeroespacial en esta en que en verdad
pude ver esto como algo que quería hacer
toda mi vida
ahora quiero preguntarles algo ustedes
creen que se puede ser experto en
cohetes viviendo en mexico
qué papel ha jugado méxico en la
historia espacial
bueno en 1957 en san luís potosí se
lanzó el primer cohete mexicano para
realizar estudios de la atmósfera sólo
dos meses después del lanzamiento del
sputnik 1 el primer satélite artificial
desarrollado por la unión soviética
en 1985 rodolfo neri vela se convierte
en el primer astronauta mexicano ya más
cerca en el 2010 se crea la agencia
espacial mexicana un organismo que nos
da la ventaja de poder colaborar con
agencias espaciales de otros otros
países
actualmente hay varias organizaciones
que buscamos el desarrollo espacial en
este sector empresas como de un lápiz
que desarrolla robótica espacial e core
beat beat 360 rock & master en la parte
de lanzadores está la asociación
aeroespacial de la facultad de
ingeniería en la unam
la asociación aerospacial decime tecomán
en el ipe en equipos como cansa
siqueiros o rocket cuauhtemoc que han
participado también en competencias
internacionales
hay también iniciativas como mujeres
hacia el espacio
estas iniciativas no son todas pero
sería largo nombrar cada una de estas
iniciativas en esta charla y ese gran
número nos habla de la capacidad que
tenemos los mexicanos para desarrollar
tecnología
y considera importante de nombrar
algunas para que los que estén viendo
esto niños jóvenes estudiantes o
personas adultas sepan que hay opciones
en las que se puedan integrar si también
quieren ser parte de este impulso
tecnológico en nuestro país
y quizá aún no estemos al nivel de
desarrollo e infraestructura de agencias
como la nasa pero podemos perfectamente
participar en proyectos de ese nivel con
ellos y de la misma forma impulsar el
desarrollo tecnológico espacial en
méxico
en ve con la iniciativa que dirijo nos
especializamos en el diseño y desarrollo
de cohetes experimentales con fines
educativos en el desarrollo de equipo
electrónico para su monitoreo control y
recuperación segura de estos cohetes
también buscamos por medio de cursos
desde nivel primaria hasta nivel
superior apoyar a los que como yo
queremos poner en práctica esa teoría
que aprendemos en la escuela y que mejor
que con tecnología espacial
actualmente somos dos opciones
educativas independientes que nos
especializamos en este sector de cohetes
experimentales pero se está trabajando
para que exista una reglamentación y una
mejor estructura que nos permita poder
formar expertos en propulsión en méjico
también buscamos que por medio de esas
iniciativas todos sepamos las cargas las
ventajas y aplicaciones que tenemos en
este sector tecnológico que cuando
escuchen tecnología espacial no piensen
sólo en otros países porque en méxico
también podemos crear tecnología y
proyectos que me den al cielo
otra cosa importante es que todos
sepamos que un proyecto espacial es
multidisciplinario en un proyecto
espacial hay psicólogos diseñadores
abogados físicos químicos médicos y por
qué no artistas también
para terminar quiero que pensemos algo
somos muy buenos en robótica somos muy
buenos en deporte porque no ser
excelentes en desarrollo de tecnología
espacial
carl sagan decía que la imaginación nos
puede llevar a mundos que jamás fueron
pero sin ella no iremos a ningún lado
cada una de estas iniciativas buscamos
darle a méxico ese cachito de esperanza
y que sepamos que nosotros también
podemos llegar a las estrellas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]